all right guys
so uh
hello everyone i'm gonna try to make it
happen this time i had some issues with
my computer last time
and to be honest i still have some
issues today so i need to i think just
change the the motherboard but whatever
um
i would like here to talk about amc gme
to start as usual then blm kf cell qs
which is a very nice company that has
huge potential guys um we are in this
trade we had the breakout at 32 so i
want to talk about this one
um let me just share the link quickly
up
live now
all right
okay so i don't know how long i'm gonna
be able guys to be with you but i'm
gonna do my best i have right now nine
person battery you can see it here and
this is the issue i have my battery is a
bit dead
so um let's
not waste any time i'm gonna check of
course the chat uh so if you have
question guys just ask me in the chat
i'm gonna have a look at that i'm gonna
try to answer but as usual i'm starting
guys with the big the two big boys with
amc and gamestop so
um let me sum up the situation quickly
then what's up bro
tesla and matt okay guys i'm gonna do uh
everything i can
just like you see the battery nine
percent is
uh what might make make me stop earlier
but i'm here with you as long as
possible so
amc we have this triangle guys i have
updated here my counting as you know i
was
uh doing something like this before and
here i was hoping this is a first wave
okay but basically this is what we're
looking for is something like this right
we're looking for the for the
for this fifth wave that is going to be
broken down into five waves as usual and
the question is when do we have the
first impulsive wave that we need to
have
in order to know that we start the new
move up so this is what we're looking
for and to find this we as usual are
gonna um
check for breakouts so here we have this
fake out as you guys saw just above 44
we closed number 44
above the blue trend line that i uh
modified a little bit and we got
strongly rejected uh in after hours
first after results it was by the rumors
the news event as we often see that in
finance guys so whenever you have some
big event coming and you see the press
action being bullish before the event
then taking profit just right after the
event is something that you might um
think about and this is exactly what a
lot of investors did with amc
grpn yes of course groupon it's a nice
one i'm gonna have a look at that hey
paula how are you nice to see you here
why are you
where are you up at this time it's like
so so late but
okay thanks for being here so uh to come
back to amc guys so a b c d e we are in
uh in an e wave all right so what do we
know about e-waves we know that they
usually develop into an abc pattern so
this is what we can expect so let's zoom
in on the first time frame and let's see
we are now looking for the end of this
e-wave because whenever the e wave would
be down maybe this would be the
beginning of the major fifths which will
start with a first wave impulse so what
kind of method do we have to know if
this e-wave is finished or not
the first method we have so like i said
we're looking for an abc
all right guys so do you see an abc here
okay
maybe
a shallow one
so it's possible that the e-wave is done
it's also possible guys that the e-wave
would be kind of a flat
and that we have you know one more move
down so here it's a 50-50 for the
short-term i'm kind of neutral at this
levels
if i see a dip i will probably buy it
and if i see a rip i will of course let
it run
um
so what what kind of signals can we use
here um to know if this e-wave is
complete first we're going to look for
resistances and whenever we are above
those resistances then it's a first
signal that the e-wave is complete and
that maybe we are standing the first
wave impulse we are looking for so what
kind of resistances do you guys see here
um
for me i see 40 the moving averages on
the forest time frame the
50 and 200 day moving averages sorry 20
and 200 are at the same level right now
around 40.6
uh let me check the retracements of this
wave and 40.6
is also the 38.2 retracement of uh what
we have for now for the e wave
so this is a level that to me if we go
above that uh it will increase the
probability that we go right away to
test the 44 level if we get rejected at
this level is totally fine it would not
be a big problem we we would probably
have a strong buying power coming here
around 36 37 level uh i myself would be
a buyer at this level
so i'm not worried at all for amc it's
looking pretty good on the medium term
very good on the long term and kind of
neutral for the short term once again
what you guys really want to see and i
told you that before and we almost had
it but it's the same thing we want to
see a clean breakout above the blue
trend line and above the 44 45 now level
so
last time as you guys can see if i go on
hourly time frame how long did we spend
above this level one two three hours
only so whenever we don't even have a
full four hour scandal the forest time
frame is very important uh as much as
important as the daily time frame guys
so just keep it in mind so we want to
have this breakout validated on the
flowers on the daily and to be confirmed
you need two candles so here we didn't
even have one for full for our candle so
that's why this breakout was not strong
and it faked out
uh so we what we want to see guys uh and
i can tell you that i would increase my
position if this happens uh we want to
see
uh price action coming at this level and
staying here you know gme i'm gonna go
go to gmu right away but this is exactly
what jamie did jamie went through this
level it was very powerful it was a
beautiful moment i mean when i was
looking at it i was so excited i was
like right this is it guys we are we are
getting to it we go to 2-800 this is my
level but i mean 800 can be more it can
be less i don't really know but
something very impulsive was about to
happen
so um
and as you guys can see
let's check how long did we spend above
that trend line you guys see not even
four hours let's check one hour
okay less than one hour guys so less
than one hour is not a breakout we are
here talking about medium term price
action analysis so
four hours daily that's the only time
frames that to me are acceptable to be
used whenever you want to identify a
breakout
so
um
i'm pretty done on amc guys so shot um
uh i'm neutral for the short term but of
course bullish on the medium and long
term and i want to see a close-up of 40
first and then 44 even 45 for at least
eight hours ideally two days then gme a
bit the same situation guys we are in
this you know same kind of pattern you
know triangles you guys know that
corrective patterns they usually are in
force waves which means that they are
continuation patterns you have some
other patterns like the wedge pattern i
don't have a wedge here
yes i have a wedge here
um
you can see on gme during this first
wave one two three four five this is to
me the first wave of the impulse of the
new move we have to 800 so it's an
impulse impulses should be broken down
into five waves just like we can see
here one two three four five and usually
fifth waves uh develop in a wedge
pattern all right so wedge pattern is
whenever you have two trend line
converging towards the same
level but
as ascending all right this is not
corrective this is going higher so this
is a wedge this is a a pattern that is
usually a reversal pattern all right so
triangle continuation wedge reversal
it's not true all the time it's just
most of the time helping to know what
can happen next so um once again when i
see a huge triangle like this i feel
like this is a continuation pattern and
i'm
waiting for the breakout above the upper
band of the triangle
all right guys so
uh gme
jamie is looking nice to me i mean you
know whenever i see this huge run up
here all right we didn't manage to stay
above true but still we went there and
you know buzz was scared buzz took her
to you know everybody took a lot here
birds to kill us then bears actually
won that day but they are still under
big pressure you can see that the
consolidation we had here just below the
trend line is a very good sign it means
we're building up energy guys this is
what we want to see before a breakout
you don't want to arrive on the breakout
uh with no more gas right you want to
arrive on a breakout full of gas full of
energy how can you check that you just
can have a look at bollinger bands or
rsi okay so here you can see we arrived
on this
high with a very extended rsi all right
so
it's less likely to hold okay now what
is is it what is happening we are
consolidating just below look at the rsi
on the daily timeframe the rsi is just
uh going lower so we are building up
energy so that we can go higher again so
it's better to arrive on a breakout with
a low rsi not oversold of course but
just medium
50 60 like right now we're 56 it's
pretty good
so we are taking back some energy you
can have a look at the bollinger bands
as well
if i add them here you can see that here
this was a good signal we were never
being here so whenever they are narrow
the rsi is close to 50 as usual guess
because we are consolidating there is no
trend i mean there is a trend but there
is no um
no no no no camp leading
uh either bulls or bears and here then
you have this candle closing above the
bollinger bands guys as you can see here
and this is a good signal after
consideration to be used to get in all
right then we have this huge run up and
right now they are quite wide as you can
see so we want to see them in our ring
again and when they're gonna narrow the
rsi is gonna come back to 50 and we're
gonna have a nice situation when another
breakout could happen so my take is that
we
lost some time all right we lost the
bullish momentum that's true for emc
that's true for gamestop guys okay here
i was extremely bullish i was all right
this is it um i'm still of course
bullish but
give it a week maybe two all right this
is my take i don't think we're gonna
break out right away if we do perfect
i'm i would be of course very happy
about that but i would not be worried if
we don't because usually after this
um fake out let's call it like it is
after this fake out you need to just
gather your strengths and like i said
consolidate a bit more get back some
energy let the buyers do the the job you
know building up some long positions
so
this is what i wanted to show you guys
on amc and gme i'm gonna have a look at
your questions quickly
how is the battery
seven percent guys so you can see it's
going lower even if it's charging uh i
want to talk about batteries as well
guys with blnk uh very interesting qs
and blm k guys those two stocks they're
basically creating batteries you know
for ev for electric vehicles you guys
know that everybody
would like to go to electric cars i mean
maybe not everybody but the big issue is
that it takes so long to find uh
somewhere to charge it right because the
technology is not developed enough and
they are not even
there are not enough places where you
can do that it takes too much time so
this is the problem we have with ev so
i'm pretty sure that those guys
that work hard on having those new
generation batteries like qs let me
start with qs
what is qs doing let's have a look guys
all right
so i'm gonna go on bloomberg
bam bam bam
okay
and i just checked so quantum escape
cooperation cooperation manufactures
automobile parts fair enough the company
offers lithium metal batteries and other
related parts all right quantum scale
serves customers in the united states
fair enough
i know this company from an ex
boss in the bank i was working
i'm not going to give his name but thank
you because i met him recently he told
me about this company he said that he's
a huge believer so i did my
job of technical analysis i arrived here
i checked this stock i think we had this
discussion around uh here maybe it was
still dropping and then i saw that we
were having this reversal signs so
uh let me explain to you first why i got
bullish on it technically and then what
is the right thing to do to me right now
so first we had this huge downtrend as
usual for most of those uh stocks that
got you know that has that had this huge
run up in a 2020 end of the year
and then we as as usual we're looking
for a breakout but after such a strong
down move move down
uh those breakouts they often end up
being fake outs right you go and then
you go lower you go up you go lower so
what you want to see is a real new high
all right because the definition of a
bull trend guys is
higher highs higher lows right
so
thoughts off we covered just checking
your questions quickly i hope the
quality is good this time last time i
had some issues
uh bam bam six percent guys i'm not
gonna waste time i need to be quick here
so uh qs we had here the breakout guys
uh and it's not enough so i didn't give
the alert at this time i was waiting for
a new high and the new high was here
guys at 32.2 and we had the 200-day
moving average i'm on the daily
timeframe that was coming here at
32.7 so what i did is that i bought uh i
was here guys i was in this move in the
scandal i was one of the buyers that
caught the momentum here above that
level why once again we had a breakout
we had a new high and we were trading
above the 200-day moving average with
increasing volume
don't forget to pay attention to volumes
if you have breakouts without volume
it's not a breakout it means you are
alone doing thinking you have a breakout
but if there is a breakout they're going
to be other traders other investors
putting their money together and you're
going to see an increase in volume so
whenever you have those signals
increasing volume breakout new high plus
you know something great about a company
that you know like i said um we need
more um more
a better technology for for those uh
to charge those electric vehicles so
whenever you have all of that together
it's uh to me a nice setup so here we
had this huge uh breakout uh that got
confirmed and now we are making new
highs so i think it's a bit late uh to
get in if i was not in
maybe i would try to catch it probably
gabrielle who is working with me on this
code who is a momentum trader i guess he
would have bought it here and put a stop
loss just below the recent law alright
so this is a trade that you guys can do
not financial advice but this is a valid
um
method so you just buy here because you
have good news you have good technicals
good company uh strong not strong
fundamentals yet but good hope of having
strong fundamentals maybe later
uh come on guys give me some likes i
have only 23 likes like come on come on
just hit this
like button guys it's gonna help uh me
and
and i'm gonna keep doing that for you
guys so here to come back on qs
we have
um
we can buy right now and then a stop
loss just below when i'm gonna be back
to france guys uh it's gonna be six
percent it's gonna be in two weeks two
three weeks guys i'm gonna be with you
on the market during us hours and i'm
gonna take live trade positions with you
i'm gonna try to apply all the methods
that i'm trying to teach you guys uh
that are for me very efficient that give
good results um you know the what is not
easy when you do that is to have a good
risk management and not let your emotion
invade you so i'm gonna work on that
with you guys it's gonna be very
interesting uh but for now the best i
can do is to give you updates when the
market is closed uh so i'm just gonna
give like you know daily updates uh
weekly uh targets you know because
otherwise um
you won't have time to
to see it before the market uh opens all
right so here like i said buy now
stop-loss just below it's a trade that
makes sense what kind of target can we
have here guys all right when you're
looking for targets the first thing you
want to do is to check uh where is the
gamma okay so i don't know if i checked
the gamma for qs so let me use my gamma
spreadsheet guys
okay
so this is my gamma spreadsheet and here
i can retrieve all the information from
the market all right so qs
bam okay we get it
that's cool
bam bam bam
bam
shift f9
all right so we have 21 of short
interest so you know the stock is
shorted i think uh like some other
stocks for bad reasons um
because
i don't know
i don't really understand how those
hedge funds
really take the short positions but
um
definitely here i think down the wrong
side
and it's very interesting to see that uh
so the
regular shot is 18
okay
so this information you can get it
everywhere and the synthetic short is
what i'm computing for you guys uh and
is right now three percent all right so
uh no sorry the market cap is not
correct uh bam bam bam
sorry i have an issue with the market
cap i lost my formula let me just get
the market cap here guys
bam
description
okay market cap 60
billion right 6 000 million 60 billion
okay just a sec i'm trying to get back
my screen bam
so 16 not 30 sorry about that bam
billion okay so it's not changing match
dtc at four so yeah what do what i see
here right away guys is something very
bullish why is it bullish
for those who are following my video you
know why this is bullish how much is
uh
the spot is right now at 40 okay so this
is the reason why we had this huge run
up between 30 and 40 all right because
we have some gamma whenever you have big
uh gamma position
sorry up
whenever you have big gamma position it
helps the market to go through levels so
just remember that it creates momentum
because option market makers need to
need to buy on the upside so here we had
some gamma at 30 35 40
and even 45 so this is telling me that
until 45 we're gonna have uh option
market makers that are gonna buy
so maybe i'm gonna start to just swing
it take profits
around 45 50. so then i'm gonna look for
a resistance level and i have here one
quite obvious at 53
do i have something else before
i have this one at 40 but it's too low
so i think i'm gonna take my first
profit um taking order taking profit
order here at 53 and i'm targeting
something like this all right so one two
three four five this is the first wave
second wave
okay
but i'm gonna take profits here try to
reload lower uh probably not take 100 of
the profits because you never know if
there is a huge rally you want to be in
it
um
so yeah this is my view for qs and very
quickly blmk guys they are doing
batteries as well
the chart is very nice this is a trade
i'm pushing for quite some time i like
this stock i like this setup we are
having here some nice
reversal signs once again breakout here
guys use a log scale don't forget just
right click here if i'm on a regular
scale you can see that the breakout is
not uh
you know we have some kind of a breakout
here as well basically the logarithmic
scale is going to give you uh
late breakouts is it good is it bad some
people would say i don't want to be late
i prefer to be a bit late but to be more
sure than that my breakout is strong
um so it really depends i personally use
log scale but as i pay attention to the
regular scale as well i just don't take
my trades based on the signals i have on
the regular scale only and here
so you can see once again our resistance
then here huge breakout re-test as usual
and right now we're pushing higher and
let me check the aftermarket guys 37.5
so it's
looking very nice we have earnings
coming soon
let me check that guys
so b n n k u s equity bam bam bam e r n
okay guys
okay i still see you here
yes i did jimmy bro just play back
you're gonna see it
tesla it's 2 a.m here andrew here bro
thank you for being up 4 p.m here in
hong kong
um so i get back to bl nk
um what was i saying yeah i was just
saying that we have the breakout that
you know it came back we tested it looks
it looks pretty good it seems to me we
have completed the first wave first
waves to to know if it's the first wave
or not because sometimes you know you
think
you don't know if it's still the
correction or if it's the new impulse
starting
is it lagging
so here we can see we have five waves
guys all right
one two three four five okay
so sometimes you don't know if it's
three or five that's true but it's just
one more information here you know it's
pretty obvious that those are five waves
so then we're looking for a second wave
pullback and then a strong massive third
wave so i think we're going to have this
third wave coming and that blm k can go
250
uh 45 50 60 let's check quickly the
synthetic shot we have over there guys
how much battery six percent
bam bam bam
blanket
and i have an issue with the market cap
i need to fix that i will fix that later
guys
okay i don't i don't see the options
here
yeah i don't see the option market here
so
okay but the the regular shot is 35
and we have a dtc at five whenever the
dtc is above three guys it means that it
can be uh it can create some troubles
for shorts
so we can see those strong impulsive
moves developing whenever we start
moving higher which we do whenever we
have a breakout so here breakout we move
higher and then you can see
that here probably the buyers were some
shorts that didn't cover higher and that
got in here some i was about here
personally as well
uh i'm in the street i'm happy to be in
um and once again i have huge targets
but i'm gonna swing it because
this is the reason why i use elliot wave
theory guys is because you know it's
just telling you that the market
develops in five waves one two three
four five so why not trying uh just to
take profits at the top of the first and
third and reload at the second and
fourth it's not that easy that's true
but you know if you just take 50 off
your position i think this is a fair
game
all right uh i wanted to talk about
fiscal and other stocks how much battery
do i have six percent
let me have a look at your questions
quickly
okay
so what do we have
islam okay everybody wants to see this
now
okay
tesla so be it
uh i'm gonna show you fisel maybe later
i want you to show your bitcoin i wanted
to show you riot mara dxy we have uh
some breakout on dxy but let's stay
focused guys we just said tesla so let's
do tesla
oh right so what do we have uh
so you guys know my view on tesla i mean
if you if you've been watching my videos
for some time you know that i'm talking
about one two thousand
uh i was talking about one thousand uh
when it was five hundred and when it was
one thousand i was talking about two
thousand all right so one hundred five
one thousand wife one thousand five
hundred and two thousand
ma targets for
tesla and let's analyze what is
happening so let me get rid of that and
let me explain to you what i'm trying to
do here and what i am see in
sorry i have some issue
okay so
um
[Music]
we had here a false wave triangle as we
often do right triangles are in false
waves we know that okay
then we had the breakout above the upper
band of the triangle which we could have
used as a buying uh
signal whenever we had the re-test of
the breakout then we had this huge
run-up so the question we're having is
how how high can it go and where are we
in terms of pullbacks and where are the
good levels to get in or to take profits
so
um
i'm just gonna do my best to answer that
question because you guys know that this
question has you know it's very
hard to give um the correct answer
before knowing what's gonna happen but
i'm still gonna try so here what i'm
seeing is one
first impulsive waves that goes uh
through the uh first breakout
uh trendline breakout breakout trend
line okay here so this is the first wave
then we put back okay we tested so
usually the re-test is the second wave
so we had one and two then third waves
you guys know are the most impulsive
ones but we don't have targets for third
waves usually there is some way to find
targets i'm going to show you
and third waves that develop in five
waves so here
i had a target at 1 300 something like
that i was basically using fit
projections based on the move we had
last year i'm not going to do it again
just go check my video on tesla that is
on youtube
uh
whatever i didn't know how high the
third wave would go
uh but i was waiting for it to be done
and now it's done okay so we have
completed the third wave okay so to me
to make sure we have really completed
the third wave uh we can check one two
three four five so okay here it's not
obvious i could do three
four and five
true
true and i
i don't know i can't be sure we have
completed the third wave but this is my
take because i would rather see a three
here we have some considerations some
pullbacks so to me this is not inside
inside a third wave it's a force wave
so i see things like this
okay so let's assume i am correct if i
am correct then
we can use the third wave
that we measure from the top the bottom
of the third wave
to the top of the third
okay we measure that
how many battery six percent
and
we
use elliot wave theory combined with
fibs that is telling us that force waves
usually go to literally 8.2 percent
retracement level so this is why 1020
was my level and i was supposed to buy
here i didn't okay
let's be honest i didn't buy why because
on that day tesla was losing 12 percent
on bad news i mean it was not it was
noise all right it was news about barry
saying that elon musk tweeted um you
know did the poll on twitter about
should he sell his tesla share or not
and barry was saying that it was to pay
his debt and some story about his
brother that um sold his shares even
before the pool you know so
basically nothing that good for
investors
and the whole market was crashing on
that day and she was losing i think 10
percent gme five percent i mean
everything was crashing so it was not a
tesla related news which for me was the
reason why i wanted to buy the dip but
uh
even though force wave usually go to the
1020 uh 38.2 percent level which is here
one was 1 1020
uh we also know that this kind of strong
moves down they create damage all right
and this damage takes some time to be
fixed you remember the minus 12
everybody that you know is trading tesla
is keeping an eye on it remembers that a
few days ago there was a very strong
move down we remember that we keep it in
mind and we fear a bit we are like oh is
it over for tesla or not and this kind
of
sentiment is what creates actually those
corrections that last a bit longer and
here i think we entered a false wave
correction that might last one week or
two so this is my view and we know that
those false wave corrections they are
usually
um zigzag triangles flats okay
so we can make a few scenarios let's
assume it's a zigzag a b c
then and we also know that for sueve
they like to correct to the
top of the preceding third sub wave or
bottom of the proceeding fourth subwave
which is here
1090
and the false wave where is it it's here
and here one thousand okay so this gives
us some area for the
correction around one thousand okay
first information and we can expect
maybe something like this
bam bam
okay
so
um
so no rush guys i am personally a buyer
lower uh lower why because when i see
such a strong move down guys you know
i just feel like bears will get at it
again
so i personally gonna buy
around
950 you see just below the 50
1000 would make sense
900 is a bit low i think 910 is better i
think not financial advice but this is
what i would personally do
um
and let's see let's see if i manage to
catch it uh if i do then we probably
gonna have a fifth wave starting when
if you don't know when you know that's
why elliot wave is very precious it's
because it's giving you
uh you can check the second wave all
right let's see how long it was lasting
one two three four five six okay two
weeks right ten days so ten trading days
is two weeks right so two weeks so right
now we had one two three four so we have
we finish so friday we finish this week
and then the whole next week so next
week i think is going to be
consolidating a period for tesla where
uh buying the deep would be appropriate
not financial advice but this is what i
would personally try to do and after
that we as usual either you know you can
there are different training methods you
can try to buy the dip like i will try
to do or you can wait for
a breakout of the trend land that we
don't have yet because we don't have the
b wave yet we are doing the b wave so
let's see how high we go but probably
we're gonna get rejected
so we're gonna be able to make a trend
line and whenever you have a breakout
above this trend line this is a signal
that can be used to enter for the fifth
wave
then
and i think i'm gonna be done with tesla
so if you guys enjoyed this don't forget
to click on the like button guys smash
that button
so here
uh
i have
i'm gonna use fib extensions fib
projections as usual to um once we have
one plus three we don't know the bottom
of the force wave yet
but
we can assume it's gonna be around one
thousand
let's say 950 okay
and now we are gonna use few projections
to know the end of the fifth wave so
what we know is that whenever the third
wave is extended which is the case here
usually fifth wave
waves they go to the 0.618 all right one
divided by the golden number which is
here 1360.
okay
this is one target we also know that it
can be a one-to-one relationship
1600 and we also know that if the fifth
wave is extended we might go to 2000
right away
true but not my preferred scenario
because we had already a very extended
third so my preferred scenario is that
this uh fifth wave
this this fifth wave goes goes to the
1600 maybe or 1400
uh i don't know something like this and
as you guys can see this is how i found
my target for the top of the major
fifths so by doing that
exercise inside the fifth wave i have
something between 1360
and 2000 so let's put it at 1 600. now
i'm going to get rid of that and i'm
going to take a step back all right
i'm going to take a step back
and i'm going to do the same thing guys
and you have seen that before and you
will see that again because this is
giving good results so you measure one
plus three you apply to the bottom of
the force
and um
we have our project field projection
levels so once again
the one two zero point six one eight is
one thousand seventy we are already
above so it uh leaves us with two levels
one to one which is at one thousand four
hundred and one two one point six one
eight which is at one thousand nine
hundred twenty so we have two different
methods that give us uh levels between
one thousand four hundred and two
thousand so
this is my view guys this is where we're
going and
and buying the dip on the bottom of the
force wave seems a good
um
i mean it's a fair trade uh i guess all
right so six percent
i'm still here let me have a look
quickly guys add your question
and sorry yeah i'm not in the right time
zone
it's a shame but it's like that
i hope the quality is good as well of
the video and of the sound
so what happened what up bro
caesar what's up man
can we make an update update on tesla
you just got it brother
and matt i'm bullish on that i'm gonna
have a look um
and let you know
i personally bought some calls well how
in the world am i going to be able to
sleep
so daddy can you take a look at nio
please yes i will do you see a pullback
to okay good question
let's have a look at nio i know that a
lot of you guys are interested into this
stock
so i'm gonna have a look right away at
it
and
it's not easy to answer okay let's be
honest the situation is like that okay
so on the medium term we are still in
the corrective pattern we gonna be out
of this corrective pattern whenever we
break the strand line all right which
level is around 47 right now so below 47
we are correcting okay now we can feel
that the breakout is coming because we
can see tesla we can see
uh the booming uh what is happening you
know on in this booming market of
electric vehicles that are doing very
well right now
so we can expect the breakout to come
right away but technically we don't have
it yet and the question that uh paola is
asking me which is a good question is
are we gonna see 3738 again i guess she
wants to buy
and
and i think we we would all right i
think we would why because
let's make a few scenarios here all
right let's make a few scenarios this is
my preferred scenario for now is that we
have completed one two three four five
why is it my perfect scenario because
after
uh
this
move down that we had here
you can see that
you know we lost momentum the macd
flattened
it doesn't look impulsive anymore all
right first waves are by the definition
impulsive there are an impulse that is
breaking out the medium term
trendline resistance which is here at
46. so we expect this first wave maybe
not to break out but is to get close to
it okay
but we didn't
so
few scenarios possible either we correct
right away
all right so i'm answering your question
right now
we might correct right away and if we do
this would be a second wave second waves
they like to go to the 61.8 retracement
which is 37.3
so 38 37
might be reached in this situation we
also have moving averages that usually
act as supports in those reversals
and the moving average would be coming
at 38 something so i would say to the 8
39 maybe to be sure
for the bottom of the second wave all
right
so in this scenario we do now let's do
another scenario that the first wave is
gonna be longer
and that actually this is still a third
wave
okay this is an alternative scenario
that
makes sense all right one two three four
five this is not a beautiful third wave
but whatever it still might be a third
wave
and let's assume that we just go there
higher and let's
make some you know
bullish assumption we go to 50 okay we
go to 50 right away we break out we go
to 50
and then we do a second wave pullback
okay
same thing i'm gonna apply fibs
to the potential top of the first wave
and i'm gonna be looking for the 61.8
percent retracement
which would be right now then at 40.
okay so in the second bullish scenario
we might still see
uh 40
in one month
so
i'm not 100 sure we're gonna see 37.38
but i would say that there is
a big chance that we see levels close to
that later and
so
i mean i think the ultimate question is
uh is it the right time to buy
i am personally longer
i would not buy right now if i was not
long because
buying
here
you know the risk reward is not amazing
if i wanted to get in and i was not
i would wait for the breakout now that
we are so close to it
uh you you see because you need to be
aware that it's possible we do like that
i mean you know this is the stock market
everything can happen so buying here
is a bit high to me before we have the
breakout before we are sure that we are
starting a new five waves move up i mean
you're never sure but before we have
many signals uh going into this
direction
so
um
so i think that
it's still an interesting level
um
so if you if i was not there already i
would probably wait for this breakout
and buy on the breakout and buy more on
the retest this is what i would do
now my preferred scenario is once again
that this third wave is complete and
that we
have we are actually doing an abc
correction and this makes sense with
tesla as well i see tesla correcting and
consolidating next week
so
why not nioh i mean this would make
sense as well right
so
so this is my answer i hope it was good
enough for you paola you can go to sleep
now if you are tired
and
and we're gonna discuss and i know more
if you want whenever you wake up
how much my tree six percent let me have
a look at the other questions
hello from seattle you're the best
andrew thank you so much so much so so
much bro
be wheels
essentially i don't know
no i think it's it's one of those stocks
that you know we were talking a lot
about before
they are not looking so great
technically i would wait for some volume
to get back to to it
before doing anything
all right so enrico
i'm enrico from italy nice to meet you
brother first of all let me express the
best appreciation thank you thank you
brother
i want to tell you
that last week matt calls during his
live stream was asking his fans for
for what youtubers
oh thank you so much bro all right
his fans
oh okay for youtubers they like him to
work with of course
i mean you know i would work i would
love to work of course with matt or trey
you know those guys they've been so you
know good for the movement for the apes
community that
they dedicated so much time and they
they did something great you know they
they have good so they're they're not
doing technical analysis so of course if
one of those wants uh me to you know
just give my view share my uh analysis
about uh mcrg for me to be a an honor of
course i would love that so thank you so
much brother let's see what they reply
yeah miss two i would love that brother
i would love that
thank you so much for
for trying thanks bro
okay
thanks here from denmark what's up bro
enrique yeah thank you brother
don't be sorry man come on
okay sorts of week off it's been a
second time people talk
to me about um
week-off accommodation distribution i'm
not aware i mean i'm aware of this
method i'm not an expert so i'm not
gonna comment on that
uh you're gonna find other youtubers
that i think do it very well um i prefer
to stay on what i know which is elliott
way theory which is also using
accumulation uh you know and
consolidations it's just you know
structuring the market in different ways
and you can associate it with fibs which
i don't think you can do with week off
so
you know what is my uh
feeling about those two method and which
one i prefer
hey morning bro
what do you think about mvis
i was in that trade twice i got stopped
twice i can have a look quickly again
tesla
910 to fill the gap yes
chris wr i agree with you
910 is a level that makes sense on tesla
let's go fisel bam all right i want you
to do fiscal i have a question about
fiscal and how much battery i have six
percent
let's do fisell
so fisel what are they doing
they are
so fuel cell energy so of course they
are
related to the energy sector
bam bam bam
okay so the commercial is fuel cell
power plant for electric power
generation
okay
so this stock i think is uh so
technicals are great uh we're gonna come
to it and
you guys know that
i mean the sectors
that i like personally is everything
that is related to electric vehicles to
energy so to batteries
gaming as well i think gaming is doing
great
um
so everything that's related to that to
me is good so i like the sector festel
is in
and let me have a look at the technicals
so we entered this trade quite early
guys uh
quite early a bit too early maybe but i
mean right now we are of course happy to
have been there early but at the
beginning it was not that obvious we
entered i think
we entered somewhere here
you see after this breakout so you can
see this breakout was a bit too early
uh because you know the
down move was too strong then it got uh
smoother
softer and we had this breakout that is
to me the right one to use and we
increased actually our position here but
whatever
right now we have breakout retest as
usual okay so let's try to count the
waves one two three
one two three
okay
this one is different it's like that
it's a one
it's a two and we are in a third okay
so
what can we expect from this wave guys
to be honest anything can happen let me
first show you on the weekly timeframe
that we have a strong resistance around
a18
so this is the reason why i think that i
would uh take profits before that and
maybe reload later if we go above that
but logarithmic scale gas connecting
highs here and here this and we have
also why did i put that put that here
okay
so i was reading a comment of a friend
that is working with me thierry hardy
soon yes i heard you bro
uh all right so
um
yes we were counting the waves so i
think we finished the first wave we
finished the second wave we are inside a
third wave
um
we are having all the characteristics of
a third wave which is taking back some
major levels and
impulsive and huge volume
let's have a look at the volume so the
highest volume was on the day of the
breakout guys of course so it confirms
it's a breakout it makes the signal
trustful and it makes the retest good to
buy
then we had this uh run up and we got
rejected first and on the 200-day moving
average i personally took a little bit
of profits here of my position
um
but i believe we can go higher but this
is just you know i think good risk
management
and then we yesterday made a new high
and we closed
for the second time
but let's see if we confirm it above the
200-day moving average which was for me
a resistance so what can we expect from
fiscal right now
so we have a resistance at
so maybe the third wave would go here
but like i said third waves they like to
take back some major levels you guys
know that this is you know a
characteristic of a third wave
so
let's see what happens around 12.5
uh i think we have
some guests to go higher now uh for
those who are not in the trade not
financial advice but do you really want
to buy here
difficult okay
difficult if you are not in from the
bottom it's difficult to buy here
because
you're not gonna trade you know
peacefully you're gonna trade like you
need it to go up right away if it goes
down you're gonna feel bad and you're
gonna take back that decision so i would
not get in right now i would wait for
the top of the third let's see where it
goes
let's see and if it goes here then i
would use the 38.2 or the 50 retracement
just like i'm doing on tesla to get in
so this is i think something good and
then if we have a third wave that is
impulsive and especially if it crosses
above 12.5
uh it's not guaranteed it's never
guaranteed but it's very likely that we
have a force wave pullback and then a
fifth wave so that's why those fifth
waves are
quite
interesting to play because once you
have one two three with a third that is
looking like you know once again volume
impulse breakouts measure level uh
taking back major levels usually you
have a force wave and then a fifth wave
so this is my view on fissile and then
can we go above 19
yes of course we can
of course we can why not it would depend
on the energy all right if you check uh
the gas for example
so
um
starting i'm i'm done on fell if you
want i can show you quickly the
synthetic short interest
you have some options
okay so market cap i need to change the
market cap
okay
4 billion
okay
okay so we have ddc at 1.6 so no big big
rush for shorts and where is the gamma
okay once again checking the gamma is
going to give you information at uh
which level we would probably go to so
here we have a lot of gamma at 15 so
this confirms the fact that if we go
close to 15 we will probably cross it
and maybe go to 1617 and you can see
that then there is no more gamma okay
maybe the gamma is going to build and
then i'm going to let you know but for
now we don't have the gamma we have a
huge resistance at 18
so i would personally take 100 of my
profits before that and i will take it
gradually
okay
so i think i'm done on fisell guys so if
you enjoyed that smash that like button
guys
and let's check what else we are having
okay
so
mvis okay i can quickly check this one
okay so nice rebound
on the 680 level
y680
i had that
not sure i added after the rebound or
not it's still looking weak
okay we had the switch pattern we we got
out and you can see that right now this
uh lower band is acting as resistance
okay i rejected once twice three four
five times so this is the first level to
go above so 950 is the first resistance
and it's not a major one let's be honest
we don't need that we don't need that
680 was a good level to buy because we
had some consolidation here but it was
risky to buy on the on the move down
like that i personally didn't do it i
was in that trade i got stopped i think
at
12 or 9
9 50 maybe the second time whatever
i might get back in you know i might get
back in but i would need to see as usual
a breakout above
what i consider to be a correction so
here abc correction this is a c wave
all right so
and we have some confluence here because
we have the 50 period moving average
coming as well
so let's see i would like to have first
the consolidation here so that we you
know we we build up this energy let me
add the rsi that is a good indicator of
how much energy is left
to go higher bam bam bam okay
so the rsi oh it was there i was just
not seeing it okay bam is right now at
50 so we have energy so let's see if we
can keep this energy and go closer to
the breakout area that is clearly at 10
50 right now uh so okay i'm adding that
mvis no problem
i'm gonna create an alert on that so
that whenever we are close to 10 15
i'm gonna have an alert popping up and i
can i would be able to tell you guys
it's time to have a look at it
okay
so just stay with me it's not gonna take
long but if i don't do it right now then
i might forget
mv
okay
i s bam i don't need this one
stop limit so that i know whenever we
get close to it
okay i don't care about the energy right
now it's gonna be a breakout
and 10 50 okay so whenever we get close
you guys can see here i have my alert
you can see right now no alerts all
right and imagine we go to 10
okay if the price goes to 10
no alert okay if the price goes to
10.4 alert okay but it's a bit late
so i'm going to put it at 10.4 okay
because i want to have my alert once we
get close to it okay now if i am at 10
you can see i have the one that is
showing up here and this is the way i
basically find my trades guys i just
select my alerts and then
i'm just checking amongst my watch list
where i have the alerts all right so
today i have errors here
then not all good to use so don't pay
attention to it
but just keep in mind that it's a good
way that you guys can do as well you
don't need much you only need a price
and
an excel spreadsheet to be able to find
your alerts doing that okay but to do
that you need to find the levels above
which you turn bullish and below which
you turn bearish so you need to know
about trend lines breakouts
fibs eliat all this stuff all right
good work on qsnbc thank you buddy
thanks bro
yeah it takes some time to learn elliot
uh
i have a free um
free training if you guys are interested
it's in the link in description of this
video
just have a look at that you know it's
like a one-hour video it's for free you
just need to uh sign up
for free of course um
to
the member area and then you can access
this video that i did one year ago but
that aged pretty well i think um
so yeah have a look at that it's
interesting i'm talking about everything
that i found in the book and about my
experience
bam bam
okay
i will do a math for let me have a look
at what other stocks you guys want to
see
in case of cell i've just done that
wkhs workhorse i don't know they had bad
news they were investigated for some bad
stuff
so wkhs i can have a look and matt i can
have a look hey brother i remember you
h-i-b-a-k
b-i-k
i don't know bro so jacobs is asking me
if there are any
price alerts and stocks
besides of trading view i don't know i
create my alerts myself and i suggest
you do the same it's easy
uh
i don't know bro i don't know so let's
have a look at
mmat
first okay
and then guys i'm gonna show you uh
quickly
something interesting about spy because
because the correction is coming i mean
pull back small
and you know we have time but it's
interesting to keep an eye on it because
whenever this correction will come
brackets will not work as good as they
are when we are in the bull market all
right
so i'm matt
okay
so i did an analysis
an analysis about this one
last week so basically i remember i did
it live with you guys i was breaking
down the price action into uh the
different waves using elliot wave theory
as usual one two three four five and i
was checking if the ratios were
respected and it was surprisingly very
well respected
uh the feed projections the the fib
ratios here the second wave went to the
61.8 percent
um
so whenever i'm not gonna do that check
again because i did it already but
whenever you know and it's true for any
indicator basically
you guys probably have some indicators
that you like to use and i suggest that
you always check
i mean probably you do it but don't
don't forget to keep doing it you check
in the past for the stock you are
considering if it was working well all
right this is what i always do with
eliot and fibs whenever i have a new
stock that i've never seen before i'm
gonna check if the ratios are respected
if the moving averages are respected
what kind of
signals are giving
good results on this particular stock
and then i'm gonna try to focus more on
those
so here elliot and fibs are working well
so
we can then try to use it again and what
i was doing last time guys
okay brother see you thank you for
telling me that you go thanks for being
here so first wave here so let's let's
check first because we never know if
it's the first wave or if it's still a
corrective wave so let's check if we if
we see five waves inside of that
i can find five waves on my hand
okay
so this looks like a first wave
quite impulsive with a strong third wave
so this is a typical first wave then
we measure this
first wave and we check where is the
second wave going and you guys know we
usually go to the 61.8 percent
retracement for second waves
and here very interestingly we went
exactly to the 61.8 retracement so this
to me looks like the bottom of the
second wave
we check if we have a breakout
and
here we do so sometimes you are not
checking the right trendline so let's
assume here that this is not the right
one because i can see the price action
is now below the moving averages so
not looking so good so maybe this one
okay
so then what can we expect
i don't see the price action going below
that let's be honest to me the bottom of
the second wave is down and you can see
you know second waves they cannot be too
long compared to first wave so the first
wave lasts uh one month the second wave
it's already two weeks
i don't see it lasting very much longer
all right so right now we are supposed
to be in the third wave so the third
wave is going to develop into five waves
as usual
okay so here
i'm not sure i'm having five waves for
example so it's not perfect
okay
and let's assume we have something like
this it's possible
so maybe this is just a little sub wave
of
the third wave so let's measure
as usual and let's see the 61.8 percent
retracement where it is
you know just doing the same thing guys
i'm zooming zooming in zooming out you
know and checking if those ratios are
respected and here the 61.8 is at 450.
so i would say that above 458
we are looking good
despite the fact that we are below the
moving averages i don't like to be below
that but let's be honest they are
very messy you can see just going up and
down crossing each other you know so
let's
just forget about we are below that uh
once again just because they are messy
and i think that we can have a strong
um
strong bank power coming right now let's
have a look at the volume the volume
going lower with the price action going
lower so it's fine i don't like to see
the price action going higher on lower
volume this is a volume divergence it's
not good it just means that buyers they
you know they are less and less buyers
so bears usually try to take control
um
so i'm still positive but i don't want
to see the price action below 450 and
what i want to see right now
is you know a clean close above all the
moving averages just like we had here
let's be honest on uh the 9th of
november it was looking very well
and then we had this pullback you know
it happens you know technical analysis
cannot do everything all right so here
it was looking very good to me uh i
bought personally i think at five
um
i'm gonna keep this position i believe
in it they are doing new material
materials
so it's like innovation it's like i
don't know the company looks great to me
and let's have a look at the synthetic
short
okay so i'm at first market cap
okay so the market cap is 1.3 billion
all right
and guys i'm going to need to go in 15
minutes i have a coal so i think matt is
the last one i'm doing
okay
so
bam
dtc at three
okay dtc at three
what was it last time
i checked it last time already so let's
see if it has changed if you have some
increase in the
short
ah you see the dtc compared to last week
4th of november i have checked
matt
and the dtc is
now at 3.2 okay
so it's growing and it's mostly coming
from the bam bam bam
the maximum synthetic shot is higher
okay
so where is the gamma
because the gamma is what's going to
help us to cross those major levels
okay
okay so we have gamma at five but the
biggest one is at ten
that's good guys
that's good why is it good because it
means that people won't be selling
before ten all right and it also means
that market makers would have to buy on
the move up all right and you can see
it's here the difference between the
synthetic shop right now and the
synthetic short
uh higher is
around five percent difference all right
so it's a lot
and i like to have this gamma under 10
strikes so it means that we can go
through the 10 strike man
that's really high
all right you see this is quite bullish
so i don't know if
okay we have many bag holders in this
stock let's be honest so we're gonna
need some good news some catalyzer to
push really the price that high 10 is a
bit high but when i see the number of
options here it makes me think that if
we get close to it
we might see
uh you know something like that all
right just bam you know just like we had
here and then i would personally if i
have not sold my position before which i
might do because let's be honest 10 is
quite far
um
i will i will take profits at you know
just above you know at 12 or 13 and then
uh be ready to reload lower after force
wave pull back and try to play the fifth
wave that here might go at much higher
levels all right let me have a look at
the chat guys and it's gonna be it for
today
all right guys give me more likes 67
likes it's good but
let's read this uh 100 level
i would make others myself
yeah you need bloomberg if you if you
want to make alerts yourself but you can
just if you
you just need to find a press action
somewhere so you can have the prices
from yahoo finance and just copy paste
you know you don't need to have live
data
so bloomberg is better but
you don't have to it's just better it's
easier
okay
smgl breaking out big okay
okay i'm breaking out big bro i don't
know
but
it's true it's looking good but this is
the issue with the stock
you never know where to put the trend
line you see
because the first one you would have put
it here
okay it gives you good reaction but then
fake out
then here same thing you can see if you
put it here then here we have a fake out
so you never know where to put those
trend lines so i don't know which
breakout you are checking bro i
personally see resistance everywhere
here so
i'm not a big fan technically of this
but let's be honest we can go to 90 but
if you see 90
not financial advice bro but i would get
away okay
and then maybe if we go above that here
it would be a nice opportunity to get
back in
okay guys thank you so much for being
there much of love from hong kong thank
you so much guys for supporting me um
i'm gonna keep doing that i'm gonna keep
updating you like i said i go back to
france at the end of the month
everything is gonna change in my life
but for the for the best um i'm gonna
stay i think uh in my hometown for a few
months uh then move to dubai
where i'm gonna teach trading so if you
guys are interested i can of course um
let you know once this is really
starting this big project we're not
fully done yet on this but basically i'm
going to be the teacher of a class
composed of students but also um
many people whatever
uh whatever the age whatever the
background you know um
and then i probably go i'm gonna go to
new york or miami so this is the target
where are of course gonna be closer to
you guys
and be able to do what i like to do
every day during the day uh so i'm very
excited for everything and once again
thank you so much guys for watching this
video and i see you soon stay close to
shore